apenas muy importante la más simbólica
de ellas la de salat de slam la corte ha
confirmado su cadena perpetua Y
reductible aunque obviamente después de
30 años como nos explicaba un abogado
hace un rato podrá intentar lograr un
beneficio carceral esa sin duda es la
más importante también su amigo de la
infancia y el hombre del sombrero de los
atentados de Bruselas de marzo del 2016
Mohamed abrines condenado a cadena
perpetua y el en cambio tiene un periodo
de 22 años a partir del cual podría
pedir la libertad condicional también se
confirman las cadenas perpetuas para
cinco de los seis acusados que no
comparecían en este proceso porque se
dan por muertos en territorio sirio
iraquí y sino también tres cadenas
perpetuas que habían sido solicitadas
por el Ministerio Público para aquellos
que se sospechaba podían cometer otro
atentado terrorista en el aeropuerto de
amsterdam o también a que pertenecían
profundamente a la célula terrorista
fueron modificadas en 30 años de cárcel
finalmente
las tres personas que ayudaron a sarab
deslan a irse desde París hasta Bruselas
el día de los atentados conocidos Como
las pequeñas manos bueno y que
comparecían por cierto libre ellos se
les dio penas más bajas de la que pedía
la fiscalía y finalmente ellos podrán
seguir en libertad en general un proceso
duro se esperaba este veredicto a las
17:30 a las 5:30 de la tarde finalmente
a las 20:23 el presidente de la corte
recordó que tenía 120 páginas para leer
pero prefirió hacer un resumen que duró
finalmente cerca de 50 minutos y hace un
rato yo les comentaba de las reacciones
que había recibido concretamente la de
un padre de una víctima chilena de Elsa
del plaza y ex marido de una chilena que
también falleció en el atentado del
bataclana ambas estaban juntos al hijo
de Elsa el nieto de Patricia San Martín
que sobrevivió a los atentados él nos
decía me fui escuchó El veredicto vino a
la corte tenía confianza en la corte
tenía razón las decisiones me parece
justa